you hear her talk about abortion when
you hear her flagrantly disregard
people's rights and bragged about it
with a smile with a smile and condemn
people who want to live in a free
country and recognize the America they
grew up in and she condemns them and
said well you know what if you do that
there's the lockdowns only gonna be
longer what do you think you're a mom
and if your son mouths back you're gonna
give another whack with the spoon you
don't have the authority to do that but
this is exactly what happens when you
have professional victims the social
justice warrior feminists left who get
any kind of power speaking of things I
don't like I wanted to talk about this
governor Gretchen Whitmer might I have
this week my finger from breaking the
toshiba did you Lisa Gateway dude you're
getting a paper cut does del genre
slogan he was great on governor Gretchen
Whitmer because he pebbles to this I
can't stand her I think she's the next
aoc she's just a different coat of paint
she is absolutely the worst governor in
the country very dangerous very wrong
and I would say evil and I mean that
because she's actually stated
motivations here I'm not falsely
attributing motivations
she has stays motivations which to me
are so disturbing it's almost like she's
saying she's the female social justice
warrior version of Donald Trump and that
she says the inside parts out loud yeah
let's go through the reasons why
governor Whitmer's is the worst governor
in the country and I want everyone else
to know because she's obviously
auditioning for VP right now the issue
she's making her decisions based on
science and if she made it let's go
through abortion first again to go
through the radical agenda that we see
from Governor Gretchen Whitmer in my
home state which I don't even recognize
anymore she actually thinks that
abortion is what makes America great all
right she hasn't had right that abortion
is what makes America great and if this
were a gaffe that were made by Donald
Trump on the other side of the coin she
said that abortions actually had to
continue under lockdown because they
were
life sustaining a woman's health care
her whole future her ability to decide
if and when she starts a family is is
not an election it is a fundamental to
her life
it is life-sustaining I didn't know that
Axelrod's face could be worse without a
Mustang life-sustaining so keep in mind
this is this is why it matters context
matters kind of like the tweet questions
let's fix that going forward elective
procedures weren't allowed in hospital
yeah right
elective procedures while she wanted
abortions to be provided at will up
until birth period pretty much that's
her world you I don't know the exact
regulations in Michigan elective
procedures included things like knee
replacements hip replacement serious
reconstructive surgery on your joints
and ligaments
those were elective but abortion is
life-sustaining which is to be clear she
actually plays this game as governor
when it's called the antonym game where
she says something she looks the exact
opposite day life-sustaining means
murder baby yeah I was trying to be more
clever by saying antonyms what that ship
has sailed
a long way 7+1 anti-semitic animals but
I think she's a fascist [ __ ] and I mean
that not everyone just her but because
before we get to the lockdowns she
outright tried to ban all vaping by the
way in her state until the judge
suspended the order it went to a higher
court and I now I think she wants to
bring it to a super yeah she still wants
tobacco flavored vapes to be available
because people don't like them exactly
is a flavor by the way they're not
extracting it from leaf of tobacco right
they're just putting an old sock juice
so that it tastes disgusting she doesn't
want the gummy flavor to be out there
because she knows people will enjoy it I
was in Michigan and I gasps stations had
these empty shelves so what used to be
there
oh those were our VIPs but the governor
says so we can't have it now so what
happens I people just buy cigarettes
here's another thing while we're talking
about the draconian measures that have
been taken the lockdown orders and
they're worse than you think in Michigan
I even just found this up because of our
brilliant researcher reg the beast I
can't take
for this she had obviously to start with
the most strict lockdown orders in the
entire nation
banning the selling of furniture paint
garden plants for you
big box stores will also have to close
areas of the store that are dedicated to
things like carpet or flooring furniture
garden centers plant nurseries or paint
now driven it's something that she has
an ax to grind because Rena Center was
after her Lucky Charms only has guess
who characters from the board game shine
crazy
no just unsightly it's worse don't worry
you can still buy liquor and weed in
Michigan yes trying to get a fern here's
something else that's important it's not
everyone's a hypocrite but this is a
different level where um she banned
obviously traveled to second residences
and to keep in mind context for people
who don't understand Michigan you have
people who don't make a lot of money
people who make middle class upper
middle upper middle class incomes
sometimes less because they have
basically shacks cottages that have been
passed down for generations and their
family and people don't believe it
because it's like the Mediterranean
being on Lake Michigan and summer it's
she's Oh beautiful
right but this is a culture of Michigan
a huge portion I think more than
anywhere else in the country they have
second homes and so she suspended travel
to for folks to their second homes right
didn't apply to people who are outside
of the state that was that's loophole
thank you Delta so her husband though
traveled to their vacation home 150
miles away to support and here's she
said to rake leaves and he actually used
his what he said do you know who I am
when you're trying to get his boat taken
off the dock over there and I believe
Elk Rapids as well we can't take your
vote off the duck because of the
governor's orders there and you know
it's Memorial Day I'm the government I'm
the governor's husband like oh well then
you're a big fat P and of course I'm not
taking your boat the guy the guy
actually said something I think I'm
Facebook or something like that he said
actually that put you to the back of the
making it look mean and she actually did
say she said my husband did go up and
for the order had been lifted but there
people were still strongly discouraged
from traveling
she's my husband did go up just to rake
leaves why it's spring so you weren't
you were going to send your husband by
him himself even though and I can't
confirm this there were multiple cars
that were there at the kind of the house
at the cottage he went up there by
himself
to Rick for an entire weekend to rake
leaves
first off I'm willing to assume that you
have helped who rakes your lead second
maybe I would buy the excuse that your
husband just was trying to get away from
you and third there is no third maybe
I'm just trying to get away from you I
just figured out as I was talking here's
the thing she responded by the way and
this is something to me that is so
disturbing and why I want everyone
please if I've done nothing share this
share this with everyone in Michigan
everyone needs to know how awful this
human being is she responded to the
criticism didn't didn't say that it
wasn't correct by the way yeah by
playing the victim effectively canceling
my own daughter's prom and graduation
ceremony but it gets worse my family has
had men with automatic rifles standing
in view of our front window outside of
her home what do you buy a violin people
have said as written results to my
suggested junk order my daughters have
seen the likeness of their mother hung
from a noose and effigy we have weather
demonstrations that were egged on that
were participated in by some the
consignor is from twilight even my
neighbors have been terrorized as they
tried to enjoy their Memorial Day
weekend up in Antrim County your
houndstooth jacket air but I was 200
miles away Oh bye wait me like he did
the hung yeah you can just when you sign
do you have to winter
oh my gosh well it you even you can
brought this up she she's the rule that
she had so you could drive from Chicago
and go up to your your lake house
somewhere right and and get around that
the point that I was making earlier
about the gardening stuff too and this
it's all these unintended consequences
she has no idea how these rules are
actually going to affect people but it's
like yeah this sounds like a good idea
let's do that and then well crap now I
want to go up to my ass when you
couldn't go out on a boat with the motor
it affects people in fishing towns who
are hundreds of miles away from her
where they don't have a single active
cage right and this is exactly why we
push back on stuff like this because
government tends to screw things up when
they do things like this don't interfere
in people's lives as much as possible
that is your job well she wants us to
believe that a woman living in it ivory
tower as tall as her sister rake leaves
punishment fairly certain he lives in
the tower too I don't think he's very
tall but neither is she either way
someone's wearing stilts that hammocks
not gonna swing itself hit the
notification bell you're subscribed all
notifications by the way on the YouTube
because it doesn't mean a whole lot and
of course we've seen some algorithmic
changes but have fun more on that soon
oops and the podcast is on Spotify the
audio version of course to subscribe at
my club let's go come on
slash mug Club if you can here's the one
that's most disturbing to me fast fact
for you we all know about the New York
nursing homes right what happened there
which affects the entire country's death
toll about yeah yes okay another
disturbing video if you have children
right get take them out here this is if
you don't remember this discover their
eyes maintaining well just don't take
him
don't take him out like Whitmer doesn't
yeah this is the man who was beating an
old person old folks home in Michigan in
case you'd forgot the clip okay all
right that's enough
horrible right and by the way thank God
not all geriatric white people are going
down burning down the local alright well
YMCA absolutely they are they just
haven't gotten there yet I'm glad they
made their voices heard slowly but
eventually do you notice me when we go
why was that guy in there in the first
place that was that that was the
question like why was he there and the
guy had mental health issues
well here's why he was there and I think
we're going to see a trend which I'll
get to him he was there because of
Whitmer's orders this was a governor's
or he tested positive for kovat and he
was sent there to quarantine Wow now I
want to be clear she just actually
renewed on May 13th
so she renewed her order by the way
since we've seen these results from New
York we not catastrophic there they are
she renewed the order on May 15th for
but it's worse than New York
forcing nursing homes to house Co vid
positive patients now here's a thing in
New York we were taking old people who
left the old folks home right to a
hospital were sick and sending them back
in like a buzzsaw which is terrible yeah
but in this case you're taking new
people who aren't old who have no
business being in an old folks home to
begin with a nursing home and sending
them in just using the nursing homes as
a quarantine it's worse than New York
and there's no way to actually find the
numbers right now in deaths in nursing
homes I've been trying to find them you
absolutely cannot find them right now
the home and the infection rates the
death rates and nursing homes think
about that for a second that guy was
there only he was beating the crap at an
old guy only because he tested positive
for Dovid Wow the governor decided that
the best idea was to send young people
with coronavirus into old folks homes
how would you want to set there cooking
the books right now and that's what we
don't the death rates that is just I
mean that I did not realize that that's
why he was there I thought he worked for
the old folks home or something yeah no
why would you somebody make it through
the screening process yeah what would
you say is your biggest shortcoming
mm-hmm sometimes I beat the [ __ ] out of
old people welcome aboard
thanks for coming listen that's my truth
[Laughter]
right well the old folks home were given
kind of you know they they were given
five grand every time that they took
somebody in for this right so you gave
them a financial incentive to be able to
do this and also they they didn't do any
inspections they didn't do inspections
at the nursing homes to see if they were
even capable of taking care of people
right I think at the time that we we had
this article there was someone so we're
like 10 or 15% of the nursing homes had
even been visited to see if they were
doing a good job right they are not
geared
for this hospital so much bandwidth that
you have and because of the
politicization that's taken place around
Cova and corner virus despite the people
trying to say you're the folks who are
anti science no no we all knew no one
had any problem with acknowledging
accepting that we needed to protect the
most vulnerable among us we old people
and people who are already sick but
because you wanted to control everyone
else through fear you ignored the one
place where everyone would find common
ground I bet if you were to poll
Americans and say hey should we send
criminals felons into old folks homes if
they test positive people said probably
not no probably not that's probably not
a good idea and this is absolutely
remarkable to me and I think this is
something we're gonna find we do have to
go to Dinesh D'Souza's in a second
there's no rhyme or reason right now a
lot of us are trying to figure out we've
said you cannot say that opening up
States has helped with coronavirus right
but you definitively cannot say that
lock downs have helped so you go along
second Florida's doing pretty New York's
doing badly and then Texas is doing well
huh it doesn't seem like lockdowns have
that much in effect why are certain
states doing better than others and
doesn't seem like urban areas are the
only factor here because Texas has a lot
of big cities here's what I think we're
going to find out now that we see what's
happened with Cuomo and once we get the
accurate in there should be an
investigation by the way into death
rates as these death numbers in Michigan
with old folks homes I think what you're
going to see is go oh history will look
back on this and go that's because of
horrible actions from individual
governors I think the delineating factor
here is that one state said you have to
take sick patients into the old folks
home another state said you have to take
not even old folks who are sick into the
old folks home and Texas said you know
what wash your hands and be responsible
yeah and Florida went to the market so
it's remarkable to me that no one is
talking about this because we should be
trying to find solutions at this point
we should be trying to look at the data
and the people who accuse us of being
the party of anti science why don't you
give us a number so we can make an
educated decision
oh I understand you're too busy helping
your husband rake leaves and breaking
out the paddle demanding that he say
thank you ma'am can I have another she's
AOC with another coat of paint this is
what happens by the way when you have a
professional victim become governor this
is the scary part imagine imagine that
person with the authority to be
President can you sink it how scary that
would pose like a what oh why did you
why did you blow up Canada well you know
and I've gotten
so much haters for having done that and
who's gonna care about Saskatchewan
someone sent me a mean letter that my
daughter had to read we don't care how
about you address the point how about
you address the science how about you
address the data how about you look out
for the freedoms and liberties that are
that are constitutionally insured to
your citizens in the state of Michigan I
haven't said this about many people
didn't say it about Barack Obama didn't
say it about Hillary Clinton I think
Barack Obama was wrong I think Hillary
Clinton's an opportunist I don't think
she actually believes anything I think
Nancy Pelosi is evil true and I think
Whitmer is evil yeah I really do I
really do when she's talking about when
you hear her talk about abortion when
you hear her flagrantly disregard
people's rights and brag about it with a
smile with a smile and condemn people
who want to live in a free country and
recognize the America they grew up in
and she condemns them and said well you
know what if you do that there's a
lockdown is only gonna be longer what do
you think you're a mom and if your son
mouths back you're gonna give them
another whack with the spoon you don't
have the authority to do that but this
is exactly what happens when you have
professional victims the social justice
warrior feminists left who get any kind
of power you know the drill just click
one of these other videos in a box
playing up here and I mean there's an
actual box I don't of course mean that
in the feminine it's a slur but that of
course I don't mean box because men can
have boxes too and I don't mean to say
box I just that men can there's like a
DC outlet an AC outlet and they can be
either one that they choose depending on
the electrical current or fats charge of
ions I think